Now it's time for you to add the functionality
to save entities to your app. Let's see how you
can achieve that. Okay. So here I'm looking at the
saveProfile method in the ConferenceAPI class. If you recall, we
already have the code to create a new profile.
We just call new on the profile, and pass in
the arguments that we need. Creating a new profile entity
is as simple as calling new on the profile class.
If we weren't using objectify, the code would be
more complicated. You already have the code to create a
new profile object, but you don't need to make
any changes now that the profile has been identified as
an entity. However, creating an entity doesn't automatically save
it in the data store. You have to explicitly save
it if you want it saved. Okay, I'm going to
go ahead and add the code to save the profile
entity in the data store. You're going to be writing
this code yourself in your own app in just
a minute. Now, I'll run the app again on
local host, and go to the APIs Explorer. So
here I am in the APIs Explorer and I'm
going to go into the Save Profile method again.
And, execute it. And have Lemon Cake as my
display name. Set my TeeShirtSize to M, and execute it.
Oops, I forgot to authorize. Let's try that again because that's not authorized.
Authorize. Now I can execute the function again, I
don't need to enter the values, just press Execute.
And there it goes. It's creating my profile. And
you see here, the request set the display name
to Lemon Cake, T shirt size to medium to
M. Response returned profile with these fields. So the
response shows that the profile was created. But this
time, hopefully it was more than created, it was actually
saved in the data store. And we can use the data store admin to check that. So
now I'm going to go to the admin console on local host. To get to the admin
console, you go to the port where your app is running, which is for me that's
localhost:8080. And then it's
/_ah/admin and this takes us to the Datastore view. The
Datastore admin for local host opens. You can see here
that it doesn't know what my app ID is. Says your
app ID, and that's okay, because local host doesn't care what
the app ID is. Course when I when actually want to
deploy to appspot I will need to provide a real app
ID. The admin console opens by default showing the Datastore Viewer.
But if you're somewhere else and you want to get back
to the Datastore Viewer, or for some reason it doesn't open
there by default, you just click this Datastore Viewer and there you are in the
Datastore Viewer. This entity kind menu shows the
different kinds of entities that are stored in
your Datastore. Right now, the only one
we've got is Profile. You'll click List Entities,
to seal the entities of that kind that
have already been saved. There'll probably be only
one entity now, which is the profile that
we just saved. So the data store viewer shows
you the entities, it shows you the properties. We've
got displayName, mainEmail, teeShirtSize. Okay, so that was just
a quick review of how to save the entity in the data store, and how to go to
the admin console on local host to look at
your entities. You're going to be doing that now.